good morning belief nation today's
message is be relentless
right over to you rob dyrdek I think
when it when it comes to understanding
tackling fear and relentless
problem-solving right it's like the
reality of learning tricks you have to
try it over and over and over and over
and keep adjusting every little aspect
of your body to ultimately get it to
work and then when you get it to work
it's like this incredible like oh my god
I can't believe I learned this and that
progression drives you even further you
know this is fantastic message and I
love thinking about skateboarders
picking up new tricks and taking them
tens and hundreds maybe thousands of
times before they actually get the move
and when you get that move you get all
excited and get that feeling of
accomplishment and it's the same thing
for entrepreneurs as you're running your
business the first time you pick up
anything you're going to suck at it and
it may take you dozens of attempts
hundreds of attempts thousands of
attempts before you get it and the way
to keep going whether you're learning
email marketing whether you're learning
sales whether you learning how to
program whether you're trying to develop
a new product a new service the way to
do it is to keep going you got to
practice you got to be relentless you
gotta practice practice practice model
success keep on practicing and
eventually you're going to get it where
a lot of entrepreneurs you give up too
soon you expect to get it on the first
try most businesses don't hit the first
try just like any feel you're trying to
pick up you're not likely to get it the
first time out and that's okay practice
and be relentless and eventually you'll
get it believe so my question of the day
today for you is what new skill are you
working on right now what are you trying
to get better at right now leave it in
the comments below i'm really curious to
find out thank you so much for watching
have an amazing day continue to believe
and i'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot events press 0